[MUSIC]
Let's give a GSB welcome to Ellen Melleli.
[SOUND].
Thank you.
Thanks.
So, how are you?
Good?
I'll be outside after this to take your
car orders.
[LAUGH] We've got some great vehicles for
you.
First of all it's really neat to be back,
in the MBA program.
And what I thought I'd do is, you're still
studying case studies, right?
Do a lot of that?
And they describe the situation, give you
lots and lots of data,
then you're supposed to think or reflect
on what you would do.
So I thought a way to introduce our
conversation
today was, let's to a case study on Ford,
okay?
And then you get to be me.
Okay?
Cuz I'm looking for a few more good ideas.
And I'm gonna get it here today.
Okay, so, it's, 2006.
It's, September.
I'm, the, the chief executive officer at
Boeing, commercial airplanes.
I'm looking forward to creating one more
Boeing airplane.
To replace maybe the 737.
80% of all the seats that are flying
worldwide are Boeing airplanes.
Feeling really good about Boeing, feeling
really good about our contribution to
safe and efficient transportation, and I
get a phone call from Bill Ford.
I'm going, Bill Ford, of like the Ford
Motor Company?
The great grandson of Henry Ford?
That's the one.
And he said, we're in really tough shape,
and I would
really like your help, and would you
consider coming to Ford.
So, I started doing my due diligence, and
at the end of the day, I was being asked
to serve a second American, and global
icon, and
I just couldn't, I just couldn't turn that
opportunity down.
So, I walk into the office in the world
headquarters of the Ford Motor
Company, the 12th floor and I look out the
window, and here's the rogue plant.
And here's where Henry Ford created the
assembly line, this
is where Mister Toyo Da of Toyota came to
visit.
To learn how to make cars and
how they continuously improve their
quality and productivity.
And here's the entire plan.
At the time it was a 100% vertically
integrated.
Most efficient operation in the world.
And I'm, reviewing the situation.
And here's the situation.
I check with our finance people and they
give me the the
great news that we are projected to lose
$17 billion in 2006.
You could run out of money really fast.
At $17 billion a year.
I also review in the situation about what
Ford has become.
And Ford has now become a house of brands.
And remember, I left Boeing to come to
Ford.
And Ford was Aston Martin, it was Jaguar,
it was Land Rover, it was Volvo.
I was, had a, had a significant
relationship with Mazda.
And so Ford was this house of brands.
And it also happened to have Ford and,
Mercury and Lincoln brands also.
Also, Henry Ford set up for it all around
the world so that he can participate in
the economy.
Not only provide great cars and trucks but
also be a part of economic
fabric of all the countries at which
Ford operated, but Ford had become very
regionalized.
And none of the Fords talked to each other
around the world.
There was no synergy.
And we were competing with the best global
companies in the world and we
had no scale, and no integration of
all the intellectual capability around the
world.
Also, in the United States, we had labor
agreements with the unions, and our cost
structure, where we really couldn't make
cars
in the United States and make them
profitably.
So we stopped doing that.
And ones that we did make were pretty
marginal.
And we focused on bigger SUVs and trucks.
So if you wanted to, if you wanted to, you
know,
live on a 150 and put your house behind it
simultaneously, you
needed to get the best truck in the world
from Ford but
we didn't have a full family of vehicles,
in the United States.
Also, we had never, we really hadn't made
a commitment to the investing class or the
competition so we were kinda competitive
on quality
and fuel efficiency and safety and really
smart design.
And.
But we weren't really best in class.
In addition, we were unprofitable in every
one of
those brands and in every model we were
losing money.
Thinking back, I wonder why I did come.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And we we're running out of cash really
fast.
So, that's the situation.
[SOUND].
I've got a card and I have a pencil.
So, please shout out what you would do.
You thought this was gonna be a free
lunch.
[LAUGHING] Okay.
Now with that situation, this is
Standford.
The MBA program.
We've got engineers, we've got business,
we've got
the smartest people in the world right
here.
Right?
OKay, what would you do?
Okay, just shout it out.
Okay, now I'm going to take notes, because
I've got
a feeling that this is going to work out
really well.
[LAUGH]
Okay, fantastic, probably over capacity.
Good.
>> Invest in R&D.
>> Good.
>> Standardize vehicle platform.
>> Standardize the platforms.
Wow, good.
>> Labor negotiations.
>> What would you do about that?
>> Try to reposition the probably long
term pensions
to be less.
>> Very good.
[LAUGH].
>> Okay, what else?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Wow, what do you mean by that?
>> Put a little more emphasis on the four
brand
of cars, not all the inferior cars.
>> Fantastic.
Fantastic.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, what else?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was, not part of the plan.
>> Although we.
>> That's what happened.
>> But that's what happened cuz we're a
real pain right now.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Wow, maybe all around the world.
>> Figure out what customers want.
>> Really?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Overhaul your design process.
Absolutely.
End of production.
Maybe do it together.
[LAUGH]
What do you think the customers really
want?
>> Safety.
[INAUDIBLE] Fuel economy.
>> Focus on quality and safety?
Entertainment.
>> Seamlessly connected to the internet.
Hands on the wheel, eyes on the road.
Bluetooth activated.
Sync my
Ford.
[SOUND] Oh man, I found the next
management team right here.
>> [LAUGH].
>> What else?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Really?
>> You mean you can't compete on a global
scale by operating regionally?
That's really
something.
>> We have a
performance culture based on discipline.
>> Whoa.
>> Lower your reliance on incentives.
[LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE] China.
[LAUGH] [LAUGH] I personally have this
philosophy if I, if I think anybody's
from China I give them a hug.
[LAUGH] Look at we'll talk about this in a
little bit but the,
the China market now as you know, is
bigger than the United States.
It's just a fabulous opportunity and I
love the Ford brand.
We're expanding as fast as we can.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now why would you do that?
>> [INAUDIBLE] brand had to be Ford and
Lincoln.
>> Oh a tweeners?
Is that a new business school expression?
>> [LAUGH].
It was a good...
We'll talk about this some more.
And again this allows you to ask some
questions that you want to
ask to, because all of these are a clear
part of the plan.
What would you do about financing?
>> Leaves you in debt.
>> You better not run out of money.
Right?
So, when you do a transformation like this
the
most important thing is when you have a
plan...
But two, do you have the finances in
place?
Cuz if you run out of money during
the, during the transformation it doesn't
work out.
So get a home improvement loan.
Got it?
Okay, what else?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Cuz they're so
cool.
Yeah.
But better have a cost structure here so
you can.
Make them here too.
I did that on the first day.
[LAUGH] Back to [UNKNOWN] oh, you
[INAUDIBLE] okay.
This
is fantastic.
And this is what we did.
And thanks for inviting me.
[LAUGH]
And I would propose to you that everything
you said
is about leaderships, cuz that's what your
class is about today.
Everything you say is about leadership.
Cuz every one of those is a courageous
decision.
It's gonna come from having a, a point of
view about the future, and
having your conviction that you're gonna
have
a comprehensive plan to implement that
compelling vision.
And just one last question.
What would you use, what would you have
used for, your vision in this situation?
Something, think of, of like what would
you have rallied everybody around?
Because you clearly are where you are, but
you're
going to different place, you just
described this different place.
What would you, what would you do about
that compelling vision?
How would you describe what your new Ford
is going to be like?
What do you think that's important?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> My god.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Oh man.
I don't know if I can wait until after
this to meet you.
>> [LAUGH].
[LAUGH]
Okay.
That's absolutely incredible.
And that's exactly what we did.
And when you walk into that same office
today, where
I walked in four and a half year ago, the.
The entire wall is filled up with Henry
Ford's vision for the Ford Motor Company
that he laid out on January 24th of 1925
in the Saturday Evening Post.
And you can Google it and find it, it's
like fantastic.
And it says, opening up the highways to
all mankind.
That's what Henry Ford was about.
He wanted to make traveling on the
highways affordable and available for all
of us.
And at the time, the only people that had
a car were, were wealthy.
He couldn't afford a car.
So, he describes in this vision how it
would have to be big in scale.
Big in scope.
To get the economies of scale.
They'd have to be a complete family
vehicle.
They have to be best in class, in safety,
in efficiency.
And have to contribute to making life more
pleasant, more useful.
Everybody will have to participate.
And at the time, January 24, 1925, he's at
the top of his game.
He has 56% market share worldwide.
Every country around the world wants Henry
to come set up his operation.
He's wildly successful by any measure, and
at the end of this advertisement for
his vision, it says that, it's not about
what Ford has done up through 1925.
But this is all about the opportunity to
serve all the people around the world.
Is that incredible?
So that's what we went back to.
He didn't, he wasn't talking about Jaguar
and Aston Martin and Landrover.
He's talking about Ford.
So we went to work and we did all those
things that you just said.
We focussed on the Ford brand.
We decided to have a complete family of
vehicles, small, medium
and large, cars, utility and trucks, in
every region around the world.
We also decided that they'd be best in
class, in quality,
in fuel efficiency, safety, really smart
design, like Sync and MyFord.
And because of our scale, you know,
[INAUDIBLE] keep
going on around the world, absolutely the
very best value.
We also decide to match our production to
the real demand, which is, what
[INAUDIBLE] pointed out;
cuz we were, cuz we were facilities for a,
you, market share is considerably higher
from years back.
So we were profitable.
We also invested in accelerated our
investment in
all these new vehicles, during the worst
of times.
So even though we're loses 17 billion
dollars.
We actually invested more during the worst
of times so we'd
be here to help everybody as part of the
accounting recovery.
The financing, we took out a small
improvement loan.
We took this, this plan to 500 banks.
We presented to 'em.
We raised 23 and a half billion dollars.
Bankers don't want your assets.
They want you to be successful.
They actually would like you to pay the
money back.
Not quite as fast as we're paying it back
now,
cuz they like to get some interest, more
interest too.
And then the last thing is we decided that
we're
gonna work together as one team for around
the world.
No matter where we operate, we're gonna
operate as one team.
And use all that energy, and that's why
you
see the new C one platform for the Focus.
And so we're gonna have ten top hats off
that new, that new platform.
And, we could be making 2 million of them,
worldwide each year, in five different
locations, and 80% of
the parts are exactly the same, all
customized to the
unique taste of the, of the consumer's
around the world.
You could imagine with that approach, what
we can do vis a vie the competition.
Okay.
That's my report to the committee.
Nice job.
Okay, now, what are you thinking about and
maybe if you
just, we've got some microphones, although
it's pretty good here, too.
And maybe just introduce yourself, and
let's just move
to a, there's so many things to talk
about...
Especially with economic development and
energy
independence and security and,
environmental sustainability.
This will be fun.
Okay, where's, this one in the middle.
Oh dear, let's just say row 18 wanted to
ask this question.
Hi there.
Oops.
Miko, nice to meet you thanks for coming.
What do you think about the sustainability
of traffic going forward?
And how, what is forward?
So what is your vision to, to make traffic
more sustainable?
>> Absolutely, this is a really important
question, and I'm really,
I'm just so pleased that the position Ford
is taking going forward.
We, part of our business is gonna be how
to we have transportation solutions, and
as you know, we
have so many cities now that are moving,
into
2, 3, 4, 10, 20 million people in, in
cities.
And so we're gonna be part of
that solution about using all modes of
transportation.
But when you look at, the specifics of
your question, I think
the technology roadmap we see going
forward, which is what we're investing in.
Is there's a lot of room to improve
the internal combustion engine both petrol
and diesel.
And that's why you see things like turbo
charging, direct fuel injection, light
weight materials, integrated electronics.
Lots of opportunity to improve.
The new Explorer, 30% improvement in fuel
mileage.
[COUGH].
>> You know, all the capability if you
need to carry seven passengers.
Then I, I, we see more
biofuels, ethanol, cellulosic, going
forward, alternative biofuels.
I think we'll then see more
electrification, always
be that component of natural gas,
especially for the
bigger vehicles, and we have the
infrastructure for the
natural gas, then you'll see more
electrification, more hybrids.
There are some plug in hybrids, and the
there are some more all electric, but the
real issue there is, the infrastructure,
and the
cost of the batteries, because today, you
have
an all electric vehicle, and the battery
alone
costs $15,000 and they weigh 700 pounds,
so,
it's nice that you and the battery can
ride along in the car, but not anybody
else.
[LAUGH].
>> but, we're working on that really hard,
and we're making a lot of progress on it.
But it's that part on the technology but
also the infrastructure.
[LAUGH].
>> But I think electrification will see
more and more.
And then, we haven't, we're still very
very positive about hydrogen.
But the issue there as you know is,
that one, you have to have the
infrastructure again.
So, it's a public-private partnership
between the governments, and
business all around the world on how you
wanna proceed.
But also, you need really efficient fuel
sales,
that are cost effective, which we don't
have today.
And you still need the very efficient
battery, cuz you're gonna
take hydrogen next to a platinum, outcomes
a water up take pipe.
And electricity goes over to the, the new,
new cap of battery.
So, kind of the same enabling
technological
box that we need to all of them.
But it's kind of that progression that
we're seeing going forward.
I think the biggest thing is that we.
We, the citizens of the world, are gonna,
play a
very important part, in making this
decision about where we go.
What do we wanna do about energy
independence and security, right?
What are we gonna do, what are we
gonna do about, generating, our
electricity clean, cuz
you can't just be working on using it
clean, but we need to generate it clean.
And then where do we wanna go with energy
policy, by going forward.
On the the sustainability [UNKNOWN] thing,
80% of
all of the Ford vehicle components are
from recycle.
So we have, very quietly moved to a place
where you really
do wanna use the minimum amount of
resources, the minimum amount of time.
Yes, sir.
>> hi.
My name's Alex.
Thank you so much for being here today.
>> Glad to be here.
>> I'm actually a joint MBA and Masters in
public policy student.
>> Very good.
>> And I, I see Ford as, basically a great
example, almost symbolizing this country.
Coming out of our, recession here, on the
one hand, a remarkable turn around story.
6.6 billion of profit last year.
Sales are up.
>> Keep, please keep going.
[LAUGH].
>> The company's looking great for the
future.
On the other hand, There's still very high
employment and employment for
Ford has you know, had made some tough
decisions which were absolutely necessary.
>> Yep.
>> And the country in some ways has
corporate profitability, it's highest
level ever last year but,
other parts of the economy aren't doing as
well and I'm wondering where we go from
here?
Do we need to accept that
U.S.manufacturing is
going to look different in the future and.
And how do, the leading companies, how
should they
think about operating in this com, in this
country and,.
>> Wow.
>> Also internationally?
>> Absolutely.
First of all thank you for your comments
as the dean pointed out is just,
this is so important for manufacturing, is
so important for.
The U.S. is so important for every country
in which we operate around the world.
Because, we are, a key part of the
solution for economic growth, right?
Also, energy independence and security.
And, also environmental sustainability.
I, I think I mentioned during our, our
conversation, with the
Dean earlier that, when I first When I
first arrived at Ford
and I started working on the
public-private partnerships and going back
to Washington D.C. I felt like I was
running drugs or guns.
You know, if you're from the auto
industry, because, they stood so tall, for
trying
to help people understand what the cost
benefits were for both fuel efficiency
and, safety.
Because we were taking a lot of costs and
materials and putting them out of.
[COUGH].
>> Reach for people to own them.
And, I'm so pleased with your comment that
where you, how you started
out because we are now, viewed as a, a
major, portion of the solution.
Ford Dollars, big issues.
And going back to the issues that you
raised,
and we, and we have to talk about it.
We have serious problems.
Now you take our trade deficit, and you
take our, budget deficit.
And this is not sustainable.
I mean, we all, have been living way
beyond our means.
For a lot of years, and we have
structural problems that we absolutely
need to address.
And [SOUND] it was mentioned, that I'm on
the President's
Export Council and also we have a
manufacturing sub committee there.
I'm just,.
so, pleased that we have now moved the
discussion over to what are we
really gonna do about the intersection
now,
of economic development and, and, and
environmental sustainability.
Because we have to do this in a
public-private partnership,
and we're the ones who are gonna have to
vote.
We can't del, you can't delegate this to
somebody else.
[COUGH].
>> These are issues that we need to decide
where we wanna take the.
The U.S., and where do we want to take our
countries, all
around the world, and how do we do that
working, working together.
So do we have a long way to go?
Yes.
Is now the time to, to really, move those
up on the agenda?
Absolutely.
I think there's no reason, why back to
your question about the United States, why
we can't compete with the best in
the world just like we're doing, with
manufacturing.
And I think it's true for every country
around the world.
As all the countries move up Maslow's
hierarchy
and create these great jobs and, great
industries.
It's gonna be so globalized that, that
operating everywhere helps everybody, and
it's not like a have or have not or zero,
sum game.
We have to move the economic development
up for everybody, right?
So I, I, I think that the most important
thing is, you got,
we just got to be competitive and the data
sets you free, right?
You, you all business people and the data
sets you absolutely free.
What does profitable growth look like?
There's only two things you have to do,
right?
Create products that people really do want
and value, and will
actually pay for, and do it more
productively than your competition.
That means use less resources and less
time.
Nanny.
[LAUGH].
>> It's taken you two years to get this
degree.
I think I've contributed to helping you
get through this.
[LAUGH].
>> Always go, go back to that.
What are we here?
What's our brand?
What do we stand for?
And, do we have a profitable growth plan
cuz
if you're not profitably growing, what are
you doing?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You're not?
You're going out of business.
Yes sir?
>> so.
>> I've never had a question asker so
close.
[LAUGH].
>> Are you okay?
>> I, I'm feeling fine, how are you?
>> Yeah, very good.
>> Okay.
So, I wanna know what you think about the,
the Google car, and is it real?
And what's the impact of that?
>> Do you know about the Google Car?
It's one of the dreams of the founders,
that have a, a autonomous car.
I really like driving.
[LAUGH].
>> now, I say this with, with all
due respect; because as an airplane person
too.
You know, we've gotten to the place now
where, most of our airplanes they can take
off
by themselves they can land by themselves,
but we
always have pilots there, and as an
engineer [COUGH].
>> You just can't anticipate everything
there's not another.
There's no, nothing like the human being,
for being able to
handle, multiple things, and analyze
things, and then deal with it.
And, with all engineering skills, you just
can't anticipate
every situation, that sophisticated
vehicles can get themselves into.
And so, I think that, that, you can write
these specific uses of it, but it be very
controlled.
And there's no reason technically, you
can't do it.
but, you can imagine all the different
issues that go along with a systems
solution.
So from Ford we could always have you, in
charge.
And you're gonna be the driver and you're
gonna
be a better driver because a sink in my
Ford.
Because you're gonna be able to use,
access all your, your information.
Your navigation, your guidance control,
your hands are gonna be, be on the wheel,
you're gonna use a five position consumer
electronics controller, and you're gonna
be voice activated.
So you can hear everything with your
voice, so you can keep
your eyes on, and you're gonna
be seamlessly connected to, our Digital
World.
>> Thank you.
[LAUGH].
>> You're welcome.
Yes sir, oh, oh I'm sorry [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
>> I got a mic.
>> Okay.
[LAUGH]
>> You win!
>> Yeah.
I'm, I'm Clay Calhoun.
And I'm a, a second year student here
>> Very good.
>> First, I wanted to say I love my Ford
Edge.
It's the best car I've ever owned.
[SOUND].
I, and second I, I worked a, a little with
GM during their restructuring.
And even more than kinda their balance
sheet, what
I though was the main problem, was the
institutional culture.
At the company, which was, you know,
management versus, labor instead of
working together.
You kind of, see sense of entitlement from
everyone there.
And from what I understand, when you
got to, Ford, things weren't all that
different.
Can you, talk about, maybe tell, some
stories as to what culture's.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Like then, and what you did to, change
the culture.
and, you know, kind of how you initiate
cultural change from the top down.
>> Absolutely wow.
I was thinking that, one of the things
Bill Ford,
that bill ford was asked one time about
the culture.
And, I think he used the Kremlin comes to
mind.
[LAUGH].
>> From a, you know, past history.
And, and you imagine what it was like at
Ford, when everybody was regionalized.
There were no skill teams like engineer
manufacturer, that went
across the company so there was no way to,
work together.
And, and everybody was scared.
It's not going very well, we're losing
money.
There's not that compelling vision where
we're going,
There's not actions in place for this,
there.
So, and, and, And problems with the
vehicles.
And, so, it was pretty.
It was a pretty tough environment,
Although, I'd say that, Ford has always
attracted, the best and the brightest,
over the years, from around the world.
I mean, none of the Wizkid stories and.
It's just, it's just this fabulous company
with
107 year history of, of innovation
throughout the years.
And so talented people, motivated people.
But, we didn't have a plan, we didn't have
a vision,
we didn't have a comprehensive strategy
and, we weren't implementing it.
So it was pretty, scary.
And everybody's kind of looking out for
themselves
and a lot of people were leaving and.
So
the only thing that I, I know to do is,
just like my days at Bollingworth.
We got to pull everybody together.
We need a compelling vision, about where
we're going, so we
all understand where we're going, so then
all the actions are explainable.
Everybody has to be on the team.
So I, I every skill team I invited.
So engineering, manufacturing, legal,
communications, every skill team, was now
on the team, on the leadership team, all
reporting to me.
And and all the business leaders from
around the world,
Asia Pacific, Americas, all there, and
then we started, what
we do, what I've always done with big
airplane program,
is that I have a weekly meeting, where we
review.
Everything associated with the plan,
everything.
So we meet at seven o'clock in the
morning, because we're trying
to honor, time changes in Shanghai, and,
and the Australia and everything else.
So we've got the clocks all up on the
wall.
We're all interneted, connected on the
internet.
We have screens that were on the round
table, we are
seeing all the leaders where ever they are
around the world.
[SOUND] One set of charts.
320 charts.
All of the plan, whether it's income
statement, balance
sheet, launches of new vehicles, it's all,
blue bars.
There's a forecast, a red diamond, which
is,
that, that leaves assessment for how it's
going.
Then that, there's a, they risk and
opportunities, all
the risk have been identified, the
opportunities have been monetized.
And so, we're looking also five years out,
so when we complete the
performance like the 6.6, or you could
also say an operating profit, 8.3.
I just might toss that in.
[LAUGH].
>> that, everybody knows what the plan is,
everybody knows what the status
of the plan is, and everybody knows the
areas that need special attention.
When you do it together, the mean goes
from seven to.
About 7 to 9.30, and then, we have guests
there, from around the world, from the
engineering, manufacturing, all, all
watching, and we meet
them, and we get their feedback at the
end.
So you can imagine how, hoe transparent
and, and close you get.
Now when we first started this.
Remember I told you that, that within a
couple of
days the forecast was that we were gonna
lose $17 billion.
So I started the business plan review, the
charts are flowing,
320 charts, we even have them color coded,
red, yellow, green.
Any change in the chart is in blue, so
there's lots
that doesn't change, all you're looking
for is what has changed.
You don't want to hear a long explanation
about what, what's going on.
But what you want is that, everybody knows
the plan, everybody knows the areas of
special attention.
So the color you got, you got the charts
going,
and I, there's about three or four weeks
of data flowing.
And all the charts are green, and I, I
stopped the meeting and I said guys.
We're gonna be $17 billion, is there
anything that's not going well?
[LAUGH].
>> Eye contact, goes to the floor.
Nobody says anything.
Now remember that closure yes about, it
wasn't okay,
to bring things up, I mean there's command
and control,.
You know, people disappeared.
[LAUGH].
>> So, I think that, and then a week went
by and they're green.
And, and of course they got me.
They got this new leader.
What, what's this leader gonna do?
And, so the next two weeks later Mark
Fields.
He was a, leader of all the Americas
business, Canada, the United States and
South America had an edge avant, in
Oakville, Canada and then actuator issue,
on
the, tailgate, so he stopped production
because
we're gonna be best in class, we're
not gonna deliver one vehicle, unless it's
done and is the best in quality.
So he had 2 or 3,000 edges.
You know, sitting out on the tundra, think
I was cold, so it went sinking in.
Cuz when you stop production.
I mean, it's a big deal.
And so up comes his chart.
For the launch of this new edge.
And it's bright red.
And I mean, you, it got so quiet.
I, I, you know what they're all thinking,
it's over, Mark's gone,
[NOISE] he's out of here, and what's this
new guy gonna do?
So, I started to clap now they knew that
was a sign the
door was gonna open someone was gonna come
in Mark's out of here.
So I could just, I could just feel it I
mean, it just and
I said Mark is there anything that we can
do to help you with that?
And before Mark could say one word, Benny
Fowler who is the head of quality now
world
wide, said Mark, I think I've seen that
issue
on a launch that we did six months ago.
Because you know in the car business you
have
so much product coming out and that's
what's so exciting.
And then Joe Hendricks, at the time, he's
a leader of [UNKNOWN] now.
Was the header of a manufacturer, and he
said you
gonna need some manufacturer engineers,
cuz as soon as you
find the problem and fix it, you're gonna
have to
change all these vehicles and get the
production going again.
I'll have those, I'll have our dynamite
talent up in Canada immediately.
And then Derek Cusack who leads product
development worldwide,
says Mark I've seen that technical issue
on
such and such five years ago or something.
I'll get right on that.
That exchange took 12 seconds.
12 seconds.
We're on to the next chart.
Course it was green.
[LAUGH] On the next shot, it's green.
The next week I think it was still red.
Mark's chart.
Everything else is green.
Next week I think he changed it to yellow
because they found a solution and now
they're implementing it.
I think the next week, it turned to green
and boom, all of
the vehicles started going and then,
probably, one of the most exciting
days of my life both from an oh, shit, I
mean this is a terrible situation.
[LAUGH] Sorry, so sorry.
[LAUGH].
>> To my gosh, we're gonna make it.
Was the following week, guess what the
charts looked like:?
They looked like a rainbow.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Like a rainbow.
And I'm, I'm going, oh, my goodness.
I'm now the data says.
Right here, why we're losing 17 billion
dollars.
Cuz the data sets you free, right?
Data tells you everything.
But, also now, it was safe enough that you
could share how it was.
You weren't red, the issue you're working
on is red.
And, matter of fact, the expectation is
that
everybody really does know what the
situation is.
Cuz you can't manage a secret.
People can't help if they don't know what
the real situation is.
And it's safe and you're not gonna get a
[UNKNOWN].
Now you can imagine the accountability
around the table.
Are you gonna be read on a item and then
you're gonna go through the
week and come back and say to all your
colleagues I was really busy last week.
I didn't have a chance to work on that.
And the pressure in a positive way is like
fantastic.
Cuz everybody there is trying to figure
out how to help go forward.
So in that one day it was probably, I was
at, it was probably like, oh my gosh.
This is really in bad shape.
But we all knew that.
On the other hand, I knew at that moment
that
we were going to be able to turn Ford
around.
So that's my, can I, can I tell you one
more?
okay, so here's another one.
In this thing about vision and, and
everybody understanding.
So I wanna tell you about the first time I
drove
in the garage of the World Headquarters of
the Ford Motor Company.
How we doing on time?
[INAUDIBLE] 15 minutes, okay.
So I left Boeing and I'm coming to Ford.
Ford.
I drive into the garage of the world
headquarters of the Ford Motor Company.
And I drive in, there's not one Ford
vehicle in the garage.
I know, I know, and I just left Boeing to
come to Ford and there
all these Ashton Martens and Jaguars and,
and I, I remember thinking to myself I
wonder what all the people in this
building are working on I don't think it's
Ford and it was Ford was 85% of the
business but Ford was kind of.
And, then I remember walking up and then
walking in that office like I shared
with you and I knew, I knew it right away,
what we had to do.
And you can imagine when the culture
change.
Can you imagine being with all those
different brands, we had
97 different models, that we were trying
to be world class at.
So, let's go work on the new Jaguar from
8:00 to 8:10, then we'll work on
the new Edge from 8:10 to 8:20, can
you imagine doing that for 97 different
things.
Business, the days when people would pay
you to manage a conglomerate, are over.
Information is ubiquitous, people wanna
know exactly what that brand stands for.
And what to expect when they walk in that
Ford's door, right?
And now they know.
It's Ford.
Full family.
Small, medium and large.
Cars, utilities, trucks.
Best in class, in quality, filters and
safety.
And you've gotta have a laser focus on
that branch.
All the suppliers know what the plan is.
All of your [UNKNOWN] customers know what
the plan is.
So, I think.
What that did to, almost unleash all the
talent inside for
it because now, everybody knew what we
were coming to work for.
They knew what we were going to do, and
that just created this, add that to the
business
plan review process and the creating value
road map
where you actually have to create value
every year.
Because this is, it's a discounted cash
flow right?
It's a wonderful think a discounted cash
All you gotta do is fill the arrows in.
The arrow's up and the arrow's down.
And if you're in business, good businesses
grow at discounted cash
flow whether it's cash or profits by 15% a
year, right?
And most good companies grow the top line
by
7% a year, by making price [INAUDIBLE]
along value.
And then they also improve their
productivity by 7%.
And what's 1.07 times 1.07?
1.15.
That's how you grow 15% a year.
That's what good companies do.
So it's just absolutely unleashed all the
talent around the world.
By, by focusing the vision, what we are,
and the
comprehensive strategy and then that
relentless implementation part by working
together.
Make sense?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yes, sir?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
>> I
>> You're okay.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] What's the biggest mistake you've
made since joining Ford?
What have you learned from it?
What would done differently?
>> Wow.
Is there another question?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I don't, I
don't know about the mistake word, I
thought.
I.
Every time I get.
You're reflecting about this all the time.
What, work you've done.
When.
Or, actions you have taken.
And, it was, And, there's not anything
that I would not
do, I think, part of the reason is, we're
in crisis, right?
And so, you have to.
You have to pull together.
You have to decide what you're going to
do.
Together and then you've gotta move
decisively and,
I don't know how we could've moved any
faster.
I'm so pleased about how we pulled
together.
I'll tell you, another thing, I wondered,
really wondered whether I was doing
the right thing by going back and
testifying on behalf of GM and Chrysler.
I mean, I'm a market person.
I really believe that market should
allocate precious resources.
Not governments, the market.
We should do it with our purchase
decision, right?
We're the ones that decide the products
are,
are successful or what companies will be
successful.
And so to go back and testify on behalf of
my
bankrupt competitors, I mean, it's a, it's
a serious question, right?
They were, they were gone they should have
been gone the market should have let it
go.
But I also at the same time believed like
two administrations and all their
economic advisors that if we would have
taken 12 to 15% of the US
GDP in the bankruptcy in the United States
we would have taken the United
States from a recession into a depression
so that's why I decided to do it.
And if you like to know how to go to a
hearing, most important thing is to fly on
your corporate jet.
[LAUGH]
Works really well.
I kept reminding them I was not there to
ask for the precious taxpayer
money, I was there supporting my, my
competitor for the good of, of the world.
And the other thing is, is to have
very thoughtful answers to their questions
is another thing.
Do you remember when, when we were, we
were
all sitting there and they were going down
asking,
Chrysler, would you, the leader, would you
work for
$1 a year, if we give you our money.
Tax-payer money.
Yes, please, thank you.
Would you work for $1 a year.
Yes.
And,
please.
And then he turned around to me and said
well Mr. [UNKNOWN] would you work for $1
per year?
I, I just couldn't think of what to say.
So I kind of rubbed my chin thoughtfully
and
I said, no I think I'm okay where I am.
>> [LAUGH].
Just got killed for that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> When I reminded them that I wasn't
there to ask them
for them for the money, but they kind of
forgot about that.
Whatever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The other thing is, is they you know,
you're sitting there and they give
you little bottles of water and the most
important thing is just to sip it.
Cos you can't get up and leave.
[LAUGH]
And we're there sometimes like 12 hours.
And so that's another important thing is
going really easy on the water.
Cuz the whole worlds watching you.
[LAUGH]
Now on a, on a really serious note.
And I think about this all the time.
A lot of people ask me, cuz this is,
you know, it's democracy and it's the way
it works.
And weren't you offended at the way you,
you were treated?
and, and cuz, you know, they were pretty
aggressive questions.
It was a serious situation.
The United States was slowing down
economically.
Here you had a significant portion of the
GDP was at risk.
And it's going to get worse.
And Hank Paulson, who is secretary of the
treasury was sitting in the same chair
that I was sitting in the day before
trying to explain where the $700 billion
went.
And everybody was scared...
And, they're anxious.
And, they're asking questions that need to
be asked.
And, so I never took it, I never took it
personally.
And, I also believe, the only way to, to
deal with
the, with things like this, is you gotta
do it together.
You gotta make it okay.
Just like we were talking about, to have a
conversation.
So, I never, I don't have any remorse for
that.
And, I, I wouldn't have done that
differently.
I think, everything on the product was
good.
So I don't think of it so much the
mistakes as that, I think that just
pulling together around
this compelling plan we decisively, that
we, that we did
it at the right time and, and doing it
fast.
And it doesn't get any better.
You know, most people tell you that, they
wish they would've done something sooner,
not waited.
I think maybe because we were in such a
terrible crisis, we had to move.
And I'm in awe that, that we moved so fast
and we're now
making the best cars and trucks in the
world that people really do want.
Yes sir.
>> My name's Marcus and thank you for your
time today.
My questions about vision.
So you talked a little bit about Ford's
globalization.
>> Yep.
>> And a lot of your competitors have
opened up plants in the United States
so...
My question is, what does it mean to be an
American car manufacturer?
>> Wow.
It kind of goes back to the question
earlier.
And I only can kind of speak from a, a
multinational, large corporation operates
around the
world with Boeing and with Ford.
And it really, is about being a global
company.
And, you can have your headquarters
somewhere.
You know the taxes and the way
you repatriate money, exchange rates and
everything.
But I really believe that the companies
that
are gonna serve and provide what people
really do
want, and do it most effectively are gonna
be one that lav, leverage their assets
world wide.
And you know, some brands are.
There's always that conversation about is,
is Amer, is the fact
that it's an American brand, does that
help you or not?
The neat thing about Ford, again, is that
when Henry set it
up everybody around the world thinks about
their Ford operation as Ford.
You know, Ford is number one, number two.
All the markets in Europe and it, and Ford
of Britain
concerned to be a British company and so
we're very fortunate.
And that's very different and like you
said the company's that, that
have, the say Asian companies have said
come to the United States.
Cuz one of the reasons they did that was
they were taking all the
wealth back home, so there's a lot
of encouragement for them to operate here
too.
But I love that Ford is in this place.
I think that what we've really done is
accelerated Henry's
original vision, actually accelerated by
operating everywhere around the world.
It's so neat to be part of the fabric,
plus
you know all the customers, you know
everything that's going on.
And you're, you're not only providing
great cars
and trucks but also great jobs and
careers.
So, I, I think the big companies that,
that have the
scale, and that's part of competing, are
gonna operate like global companies.
>> Guy with the mic.
>> My name is Guy with the mic [SOUND.]
I'm Chen, first year, Alan great to have
you here.
My question is about, I'm Chinese too so
you owe me a hug.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Sorry.
My question is actually about jobs.
So things I wanted to point out, you
caught 40% of the, the workforce at Ford.
And, and you know, I think it's an
understatement, given the overcapacity and
other industry in general.
But you know, I think so much about the
debate about economic
growth right now is about bringing jobs
back, are those jobs coming back?
And do you see the auto industry grow as
bringing the jobs back?
>> Absolutely and we just announced, well
can I come back up just a
little bit to your, to your start of your
question, because it's really important?
This is about business and, this is about
profitability growing.
And you've got to do whatever it takes,
because if, just like the situation we
described, you couldn't go very many years
losing $17 billion, and then you're gone,
right?
So you have to size yourself to the real
demand no matter what.
Remember in the automobile industry,
because all their costs
they thought were fixed, then they'd keep
their production up...
Over deliver all these vehicles, just to
get the last incremental dollar,
cuz if, couldn't, didn't think they could
do anything about their cost.
So what we did is we went to the to the
unions
and we talked about a future where we
could actually make cars in
the United States, but we had to have our
cost structure right and
we had to size ourselves in the near term,
to the lower demand.
Well, we agreed, because you, we came
together around this vision
of profit growing and actually hiring,
hiring and providing great jobs.
But you gotta take the tough action to get
yourself
started so you can keep investing during
the toughest of times.
So and it's hard.
I mean it's, you don't, you don't any way
want to go through that.
That's why, this economic development
worldwide is so important.
Now having said that we sized ourself to
the real demand.
We took out all the extra production both,
as somebody mentioned earlier also with
our distribution channel.
And with Ford and with our suppliers.
And so now we're operating profitably at
the lower demand.
And, and we invest it for these new
products.
So now, we just announced over the next
two years, we're gonna hire 7,000, new
employees.
And just give you one example, we're
making the new Explorer in Chicago.
That's the one that's 30% more efficient
than our last one.
And we'll be exporting that vehicle to 94
countries around the world.
And in that plant alone we'll be adding
1,200 jobs and
then another 600 jobs with 100 suppliers
throughout the United States.
And all of our suppliers now are all
global.
Cuz, which, when you operate this way you
use your scale globally but
then you operate locally so then you get
the best of both both worlds.
So, and our plan is to fundamentally now,
to grow the business
year after year forever cuz that's, that's
the purpose of a business.
So, we're really excited about how
everybody
pulled together to get to this place.
And now it's really exciting now to grow
and provide all these great opportunities.
In Asia Pacific, we're grow, we're one
of the fastest growing companies in Asia
Pacific.
Find tremendous opportunities.
Great market in Europe, a little bit
slower growth, a little bit more mature.
Fabulous growth in Brazil, Russia.
And especially in India and China.
Okay, maybe one last question because I
hear that
when it gets close, you get up and leave.
>> Here.
>> Yeah.
>> My name is Pragosh, I was at the
consumer electronic show at Las Vegas.
>> Were you really?
And, I got to check out your, your Ford
Sync.
>> What'd you think?
>> And, I love the voice activated
experience, but I
was wondering, are you guys thinking about
a app store?
Much like how Apple came out with theirs,
for their hardware.
>> Right.
>> Are you coming out with an app store
for your hardware?
>> We're, we're not, right now, but you
saw the apps that we were managing now.
And, we also have all the app producers
that
are working on what's makes sense for a
car.
The real thing we decided was, was to not
get in that as a business
like Apple did but, but to focus
on the automobile and the safe driving
experience.
So we're not making any money on all those
apps ourselves.
We could have taken a, a piece of each
of those like other business models that
you know of.
Because what we, what we want to do is a
ha,
was to make sure that everybody when they
bought a Ford.
That they could seamlessly operate and
yet, be connected to a digital world.
So we're managing that interface that you
saw with
sync and My Ford and that's been our, our
focus.
Now a lot of people have wanted this, you
know
when Pandora comes in or any, you know,
other applications.
They would like, a lot would like us to do
a business with them but right now we're
focused on providing
a better driving experience and a safer
experience than having
all of us have access to the internet for
right now.
Yes.
>> Thanks again for joining us and I
appreciate getting to ask the last [COUGH]
question.
My name is Caroline Mellon, I'm a first
year here and I had the honor
while I was at Deutsche Bank, before
Stanford of working with the Ford Credit
team.
Oh, very good.
I wanted to know what you thought their
role was in the
turnaround of Ford in 2009 and their
active, kind of intensive balance
sheet management, and then what your
objectives are for balance sheet
management
as your positioning for growth, but also
preparing for another potential crisis.
>> Fantastic.
It sounded like you had a great experience
at the bank, too.
[LAUGH]
>> They're, they're, they're one of our
main bankers, too.
And they're fantastic.
What what she is referring to is what we
call Ford Motor Credit Corporation.
And it's a Captive Finance Company that we
have.
Meaning that we own it.
And it's cost the Capital goes with the
parent with Ford.
As opposed to, you know, independent bank.
This has been really important for Ford,
because as you go through these
cycles, let's see, your banker friends
kind of come and go a little bit.
and, I mean, cuz they're managing their
life too.
And, but, but the reason we have a, a Ford
credit
corporation is that during the worst of
times, the best of times,
then we can continue to help with the
financing for all of
our Ford store owners with all their,
their inventory, all their vehicles.
We also have one-stop shopping.
So when you walk into a Ford store, you
can
get your financing for the vehicle, in
addition to the vehicle.
And remember when when we went through
this crisis GM, and they're trying to work
their cash so carefully they actually sold
GMAC,
which they, which was their captive
finance company.
So we really believe we've, we've done the
right thing.
It really helped us get through this.
Right now we have scaled back Ford Credit
with the divestor of all these other
brands.
But now they're really right sized and
they're just
an absolute key part of our business going
forward.
And I'm just so pleased that we keep that
as a priority to keep that captive finance
company.
And now on our balance sheet, now it just
gets better and better.
You saw last year.
That, you know, when you borrow $23.5
million, you need to pay it back, and
it's a wonderful thing to be paying back
our banks, and our goal of
course is to move back to investment grade
because our cost of capital goes down.
That makes that allows us to invest more
in the products but also
allows for credit to be even more
competitive on helping you with loans.
So last year we paid $14.5 billion back on
our loans, which is fantastic and,
we'll probably, keep some debt cuz, you
know, it's good to leverage, a little bit.
But we're clearly moving back to
investment
rate, a lot faster than what everybody
thought.
And most important thing is you're growing
the business profitably, generating free
cash flow.
And it gives you great options not only on
improving the balance sheet, but also on
the products.
okay.
I know you're gonna get up and leave.
And, and I would take it personally if I
wasn't done, so I'm gonna be done.
I, was honored, to get a request to come
here.
I, I grew up in Kansas, I grew up in
Seattle, Lebowing.
We've had tremendous programs with
Stanford over the years.
It's a fabulous school, as you know.
You're getting, one of the finest
educations, and
you're also getting one of the best global
educations.
And it's so important, for where the
world's going and
so, thank you for the invitation and,
congratulations, to you.
I look forward to working with you.
I would love you to consider maybe Ford,
as you're considering going forward.
And also,
maybe you should drive a Ford, and feel
the difference.
Thanks a lot.
[SOUND].
>> Thank you.
Thank you.